one of the key points about Britain
today is that the the New Elites are
united unlike the old Elite by a set of
liberal Cosmopolitan views and by that I
mean they're much more aggressively
pro-immigration they're much more
supportive of returning Britain to the
European Union they're much more
Universalist in how they think about
identity so they're not really
interested in Britain's distinctive
identity history and culture which
millions of people really do cherish
they want to keep Britain distinct the
new Elite is really much more interested
in reshaping our national identity
around International themes like
diversity or multiculturalism and
there's as I said at the conference you
know there's nothing wrong in saying
that Britain is welcoming and diverse
but diversity cannot be the basis of our
national identity because it's like
saying we don't have an identity of Our
Own